all right let's do it
so thank you everyone for coming early
this morning
day two of NDC Oslo it's been great so
far yeah it was my first trip to
Scandinavia so I'm just having a great
time although I am based in Phoenix
Arizona USA where it is a lovely 30
degrees Celsius right now at midnight
um
so it has been a bit cold but I'm I'm
very tall I'm a solution architect and
developer for carvana based in Phoenix
and uh I am the kind of person that
keeps a list of his favorite physicists
and his favorite mathematicians so that
right there probably tells you
everything you really need to know about
me explains pretty much any Behavior you
might see what's he do oh favorite
physicist mathematicians right but of
course I also love to talk about such a
list so please feel free to tweet at me
tell me who I left off the list that
should be there who is on the list that
shouldn't be there
Etc
um that's Twitter so we'll do that we'll
keep that conversation going on Twitter
um so besides being the kind of person
that does keep such a list I am also an
open source contributor I have a number
of projects that I Shepherd none of them
particularly germane to this talk so I'm
not really going to go into any of them
other than to point out that the first
one liquid Victor is the one that I use
to put together these presentation
slides
and this uh slide is a little more
germane for uh people in the U.S but uh
carvana is an amazing place to work so
if you're looking for work in the United
States please feel free to check it out
I'm also an organizer of uh give camp
and there are give camps all over the
world now so if you're familiar with it
or if you're not it's a weekend event
where we put a bunch of software
creators that's you guys
um in a room with a bunch of great local
charities and we code for the weekend
and turn that code over to the Charities
at the end of the weekend it's quite an
amazing experience very agile and as our
friend Rob Richardson who is spoken here
in the past likes to say he works with
me on it he likes to say that sleep is
optional caffeine is provided so
uh finally on a little bit more personal
note before we get into the content
um a few months ago I gave my 100th
public talk and that kind of thing is
just not possible without these amazing
communities
um so all of you for making this
community happen all of the volunteers
who actually do all of the work and I
just get to travel around the world and
and have fun talking to you guys
all the sponsors who make this possible
thank you all because uh
I would never get to do these kinds of
things if it wasn't for this community
and I appreciate every minute of it so
thank you
[Applause]
all right we're going to talk about
algorithms today
um we won't be talking about sorting
algorithms today not because they're not
cool just because there's a lot of other
types of things out there that we can
learn and we're going to particularly
focus on algorithms that where we've
learned them from Nature Nature has had
four billion years of evolution to
optimize
these kinds of things and to figure out
what the best ways are
to solve problems you could call it the
word the original genetic algorithm
right
so we're going to talk about some of
those so here's what here's what we'll
look at we'll look at two different best
path algorithms that come from
nature we'll look at two different cost
reduction algorithms we'll talk about
what that means and
how we can use them by applying one of
them
to an AI model and we will use one of
those in place of say gradient descent
or one of the other
uh algorithms that can be used to train
in a machine learning model
sound good
all right
so let's start with best path
so this is a simulation I put together
of a bee Colony optimization so I'll use
the same
um this same simulation uh
set up for the the next type of best
path as well so what you see here are 20
nodes and I've arranged them in a circle
so it's easy to see when the best path
has been found the best path of course
for uh nodes in a circle is just around
the outside of the circle so it's easy
to see if we found the best path or not
and then we're starting
we don't know what the best path is so
we're just trying to find it so we start
off with lines going all over the place
and then we start running this B Colony
optimization
and you can see eventually it gets
almost to the point of actually finding
what is easy to see is the best solution
so how does this work what do we what
are we doing here well there are
actually three types of bees that we use
in a b Colony simulation
the first is an active worker
then there are scouts and inactive
workers
okay active workers they forage on a
known path and a neighboring path so
they do what's called a neighborhood
search
they know their path they know the
length of it and they try a neighboring
path and they check the length of that
and they see if which one's better and
if it's better they move to that
Scouts on the other hand use a random
path
so this is a combination algorithm this
is one where you're using a combination
of neighborhood search and random search
so we get some flexibility there and
then finally there are inactive workers
and inactive workers have a very
interesting role they basically take
their um their starting point from the
best path found from other bees
and then they get rotated in
so let's see how that works let's see if
we can make this thing
display well
if I
open a new tab
nope
one more try
nope not gonna work all right hopefully
you can you can see that okay if not the
slide deck is already up on on the
internet uh amazing
algorithms.azurewebsites.net it's linked
at the end so you'll have these also by
the way on the uh second slide of each
one of them there is the pseudo code for
this so for each of the algorithms so
you could take that pseudocode copy
paste it in as comments into whatever
language you're interested in trying it
in and use that as a foundation for
starting to put this together
all right so what do we do with bee
Colony well basically what we're doing
is we're going to cycle through a bunch
of times we're going to use we're going
to pick some number of epics
which is the full Cycles
there are sometimes better ways to stop
I've kept it simple for this so you know
we're just going to run n number of
times maybe 10 000 times or something
like that but we could look for like
when the solution stops changing that's
another way of in fact maybe a better
way of
trying to to tell our our algorithm when
to stop
then we're going to look at Loop through
each B
that we have maybe we'll start with a
hundred B's uh 70 of which are active
workers 20 Scouts and 10 inactive
workers Maybe
and
depending on what type of B it is
if it's an inactive worker we're just
going to ignore them for now
but if it's an active worker we know the
length of their path they have a defined
path and what they're going to do is
we're just going to pick two nodes and
swap them
and they're going to check that
neighborhood so they're going to check a
path that's neighboring to the current
path and see if that's shorter
if it is that becomes their New Path
there's one more thing we do at this
point we check and see compared with all
the other bees does is did this this new
path that we found that was shorter
is it the shortest path found so far
and if it is we get to do the waggle
dance
that's where bees go and tell the
inactive workers
here's where I found the food here's the
shortest path that I've found to the
food
and those inactive workers have some
percentage chance of being convinced
maybe a 90 chance
that that's the best path to the food
and they take that path as their path so
that when they're rotated in
now they start with that as their path
and they explore neighboring paths to
that but there's only a 90 chance of
them being convinced or so you can tweak
that value
that means that they may have the
previous solution they may still have a
random solution from the very beginning
when we start they all have a random
solution
so we get some element of randomness
we get a lot of paths explored
and then of course we get our Scouts
which are totally exploring random paths
at all times
so
it helps us not um get trapped in a what
we'd call a local Minima where if we
find a fairly short path
but not the shortest path
we might still find the shortest path
that's going some other direction
because we have these random things
being explored and because we're
exploring neighborhoods
this all making sense so far
all right
so be Colony optimization
well we have the advantages of it being
multiple search types neighborhood
search random search and that we
propagate the currently best known
solution to other inactive workers
there are a lot of things we can a lot
of knobs we can turn a lot of dials we
can twist on this one uh we can change
the number of each types of bees or the
number of bees that we use in the
solution
we can change the probability of
persuasion so how easy is it to convince
one of the inactive workers that that's
the best solution and they should change
to
that that solution that was just found
um
and also how often we swap out active
workers for inactive workers we can
tweak all of these little these features
now these these algorithms are nice
because they're not that I mean they're
the scale you can scale them out to huge
um problems
and they can still find usually a good
enough solution
but
unlike algorithms where you're doing an
exhaustive search where you're checking
everything you can never be guaranteed
optimality so we never know for sure
that we find the best solution
but of course if it's an exhaustive
search and the problem is huge we'll
never finish either so we'd never be
guaranteed optimality there either
sound good I want to check out ant
colony optimization
all right
same simulation
uh we're looking we've got those 20
nodes around the outside we're trying to
find the best path you can see that this
one doesn't get as good a solution in as
many uh epochs as I allowed it to
to try
and this is a completely different type
of search algorithm
so in this case we're basing everything
on pheromones so if you've ever gotten
ants in your house I don't know how how
big a problem that is here in Arizona
certainly uh if you get ants coming in
your house you have to stop it right
away
you have to do something immediately
because they lay down pheromones as they
walk
and other Pat ants can follow that path
so if you get a few ants coming on a
single path you're going to get a lot
more
so we use this
to optimize our our search and ants use
it to optimize their path to their food
because the more a path has been used
the more pheromones are left on it which
means it's more likely that other ants
are going to take that path
so we're going to explore an example of
that
so this is the flowchart for uh for ant
colony and again like like the other one
we have
pseudocode there for it that you can
check out and use if you wish for ants
all we're really doing is we're only
going to have a few ants like we're
going to have four ants
and we're going to Loop through each of
those ants we're going to put them in
random places so they can start in
random places because you know this is
uh we're making a complete traversal we
have to get to all 20 nodes so it
doesn't really matter where they start
the path is going to be the same
regardless of where you start so we put
them in random places and then allow
them to start exploring
and so each ant moves
one node to the next and the way it
makes that decision
as to which node it goes to next is
based on the amount of pheromones so
it's proportional
the probability of it taking that path
is proportional to the amount of
pheromone left on that path so at the
beginning we probably have no pheromones
anywhere when we first start so it means
it's an even probability equal
probabilities of going to any of the
other 19 nodes in this
in the solution
as we go though as they
march on if you will
they leave pheromone behind them
and the interesting part is that the
pheromone dissipates
so the amount of pheromone gets weaker
over time which means the longer it
takes for them to go out and and finish
their circuit
the more a pheromone has evaporated so
the longer the path
the less pheromone is left on the path
you see where I'm going with this
right so the shorter paths will have
more pheromones left on them at the end
of each epoch which means they're going
to be more likely to be taken by the
next stand
or them
so that's the gist of it um
so we keep doing that we keep looping
through and eventually we're going to
start getting a bunch of pheromone built
up on these shorter paths
now we have to have some kind of
calculation that tells us how to reduce
the amount of pheromones so that's going
to be one of the things we can tweak is
how fast does the pheromone dissipate
and we'll have to calculate at the end
of each circuit we're going to have to
calculate how long was that path and
then inversely proportional to that
we'll have to remove some pheromone from
that to simulate the evaporation of the
pheromone
it's actually kind of a fun one to
implement if you're going to if you want
to explore best paths I I do recommend
starting with this one playing with it a
little bit it's kind of fun
uh now of course it's easy to get stuck
in a local Minima on this one because
you can see you can
as you start
getting you know One path having a lot
of pheromones it's going to start
converging on that because more ants are
going to take that and you're going to
kind of snowball so you can get caught
in a local minimum so you want to be
careful about that you want to have a a
method for handling that maybe it's just
run the full simulation multiple times
with you know starting in random places
because there is an element of
Randomness a significant element of
Randomness to this
and like the
bee Colony it is
not guaranteed to be optimal because
it's not an exhaustive search
but it is also
it scales pretty well
yeah you're not gonna
exhaust your Computing capabilities
because you tried to exhaustively search
a an untractable problem
all right
let's take a look at ways to reduce
costs now costs remember in this can be
money but it can also be time it can be
expenses it can be error
we'll look at error here in a little bit
for the two examples we're going to look
at we're going to use this function this
is the mikhailovich function and it's
used basically to test these kind of
optimization routines because they have
that deep blue
dip in the in the middle there
that's our minimum that's our minimum
point and we want to find that point
but there's other local Minima that we
could get caught in so we have to have
ways of of dealing with that
so what you're about to see here
is a simulation of firefly optimization
so this is a swarm of fireflies
that are trying to find the best
solution and they're looking to they're
swarming to the brightest other
fireflies so they swarm towards each
other
depending on how bright the other
fireflies are and the brightness of a
firefly is directly proportional to the
quality of the solution meaning the
lower the cost the brighter the Firefly
the more other fireflies swarm to it
this one's a fun one too
so what we do here is we start by
scattering a bunch of fireflies out
randomly and we can use I think I used
40 in this in this scenario for this
size problem but you know you'll scale
the number of fireflies to your solution
and then we Loop through each of the
fireflies and we find
actually we looped through each pair of
fireflies so for every combination and
that that Cartesian product of the two
fireflies for each pair
which one's brighter
how much brighter is the other one
relative to that one
and then how far apart are they and then
we move the dimmer one towards the
brighter one
you I it's the easiest way to to equate
it is the the law of gravity
um the it is directly proportional to
the brightness or the mass in the in
terms of gravity and inversely
proportional to the square of the
distance between them so the further
apart they are
the less attractive they are to each
other
the brighter they are the more
attractive
and we move the dimmer one towards the
brighter one using that kind of equation
it's actually a lot simpler than it
sounds
um and what what ends up happening is
you saw on the simulation pay attention
to the Red Dot there
what ends up happening is that red dot
is representing the Firefly that has the
best solution right now so that's the
brightest one
so when it looks like it's jumping
around it's not that a firefly is
jumping it's that it's changing
fireflies because that other Firefly
found a better solution
so they keep swarming towards
better Solutions but they're not just
sorting swarming towards the best one
they're swarming towards other brighter
fireflies too
so they explore a lot of the area
towards
the best solution so you get a lot of
coverage especially as you get closer to
the best solution
but like all optimization algorithms
they have their
it has its difficulties
uh
for one thing it works best for linear
problems so if you can kind of picture
it if you think about the simulation if
it was a discrete problem if it was
problems where only integer values were
usable
it would be hopping around and it
wouldn't really be good at it you know
it doesn't have a good space to explore
where if it's a linear problem so you've
got you know an infinite number of
values to explore it does a really good
job of exploring that there are better
solutions for uh integral problems for
discrete type problems
and of course optimality is not
guaranteed again with this one we have
another interesting problem and that is
it can suffer from sparseness
um
think about this if I were
looking to find the densest matter in
this room
and I scatter a bunch of fireflies
around well there's a lot of matter
close to the floor and the stage and
what have you but there's not a lot of
matter up in this area up here you know
higher so if a lot of my fireflies end
up up there
we might have a tough time finding that
all the the matter is lower right
probably the thickest is this skull
anyways
[Music]
um
and then think about that
say in this kind of scenario where if
we're trying to find the densest matter
there what are the odds no matter how
many fireflies I scatter about because
this space is so sparse
what are the odds of us actually finding
uh some some manner of some level of
density of matter
and then it gets worse and worse as you
add Dimensions so now if I add time onto
this as as a dimension where I have to
think about that now
there's hardly any points in that that
four-dimensional space time
say words uh in that in that area where
there is actually dense matter so it can
be very very hard with this type of
algorithm to actually find a good
solution
something you have to consider
all right
last one
let's talk about
the amoeba
amoeba is forage for food and they do so
with uh
using a an algorithm if you will that
they have
used for billions of years now I don't
know when the amoebas came around but I
know it was a long time ago
um
so what you're going to see uh here is a
simulation of an amoeba with three that
I used with three three points so it
makes a nice triangle makes it easy to
see how it moves about
and we're simulating the foraging
behavior of an amoeba amoebas look for
you know protein rich or
carbohydrate-rich I think it's
carbohydrates
um
they look for carbohydrate-rich
environments and then they surround it
and they contract on it
and then utilize it I assume
so we're going to search for our best
solution using a method like this now I
said I have three points on the amoeba
here you can use arbitrary numbers of
points in fact I would recommend
depending on the number of dimensions in
your problem
that you use more points on your amoeba
than you have dimensions in your problem
but this one's a nice simple looking
flowchart
there is a a significant calculation
here and we'll get to that
but primarily all we're doing is we're
randomly starting putting our our you
know random three points
see which one's best
and then we move the amoeba around in a
way that's defined by this simulation of
their foraging Behavior
eventually contract on on the solution
so here is the the interesting part of
this one
what you can see here is that we have an
amoeba with three points
and then we have a centroid so there's
the the one on the left is the best
solution found so far
okay
the other two points are less
they're less carbohydrate Rich right
they're they're not as efficient
so what we're going to do is we're going
to find a centroid the point between
the uh the two other Solutions
and if there's more than two it's still
the average point between all the other
Solutions okay that's our centroid we're
going to draw a line between the best
solution and the centroid and then we're
going to pick three points on that line
we're going to find the best solution of
for those three points of those three
points and then we're going to move the
worst solution the worst point on the
amoeba to the best of those new three
those three points are the what is it
called the contracted reflected and
expanded so the contracted is the median
point between the best solution and the
centroid
the reflected is you reflect that
across
and then the expanded as you double it
out
and one of those three points is likely
to be better than the worst one
then the worst one you have so far and
you move that worst point there and
that's how the amoeba moves around now
what do you do if
the all of those three points are
actually worse than the worst solution
you have so far
what we hope that means is that you
we've surrounded the best solution
already
and at that point we need to contract so
then we contract the amoeba
and see if we're condensing on the
proper solution
so
amoebas are a neighborhood search
right it's searching in the area based
on that
centroid
we surround the solution we contract on
it there's a number of things we can
tweak we can tweak the size and the
number you know the number of points of
the amoeba
and we can also affect the number of
executions so we want to look out for
those local Minima and again optimality
is not guaranteed and it can suffer from
sparseness if it simply cannot find
as far out as we've as we've tried it it
can't find
points where there's uh there's good
Solutions it's going to have trouble
so we're going to want to probably run
it a number of times
cool so we've got these algorithms what
can we do with them
all right let's uh let's get a little
background here
we've got some data and it's clearly
linear data right I mean that's that's
pretty obvious that it's linear with
some noise
but there's there's definitely some
linear data there if we want to
predict one of the points on that line
based on the other so if we want to if
we have the um
x-axis value and we want to predict the
y-axis value there
we can do a simple linear regression
right and Excel does that for us it will
draw a best fit line
all we're doing there is we're
figuring out how we can predict y
knowing X
there's another way we could do that we
don't need to do it this way but there
is a another more interesting way of
doing it and that's with
a a machine learning type model
where it's the very simplest of these
models it's only got one input and one
output the input is X the output is y
and between them it has a single edge
so edges and machine learning models
have weights so we have to figure out
what the weight is of that edge
and output nodes calculated nodes
have a bias
so on this chart here I've called the
weight M and the bias B
and we have to figure out what those are
and so if you think about the letters
that I chose there you might see that
those were intentional because what
we're actually looking for when we make
that prediction is we want to calculate
y so Y is equal to
we multiply the weight times the input M
times x and then we add in the bias plus
b y equals MX plus b as we all remember
from first year algebra is of course the
equation for a line
so all we're doing when we find M the
slope
and B the offset
we're finding the values that minimize
the error
in that line
and whatever minimizes that error that's
our best fit line
right I'm seeing some head knots I'm
feeling pretty good about this
if we look at the error function here
you could see that it it varies greatly
with the slope which totally makes sense
right if we have the slope opposite the
opposite what of the actual data it's
not going to fit at all we're going to
have a huge error
but as we get the slope right it comes
down to the V and it's hard to see in
this uh you'll be able to see it when
you have it locally but there's actually
another V in the trough
at the bottom there and that's where we
have that's when we're adjusting that
bias as we get that bias right as we
move that up and down we find our best
fit line so our error is then minimized
so that's what you're doing when you
train an ml model is you're finding the
minimum point on the error function
graph
we can do that with much more
interesting things so let's take a
different model
this is a model that I built for
predicting the
political party of a vote of U.S
Congress members
so this data is from the 80s back when
it was a lot harder to predict what
people were going what party they were
from based on their votes uh but as we
see we'll see later wasn't all that hard
even then
um
so what we have is we have data that had
about 430 data points or so 430
different votes uh sorry 430 different
Congress people
and each of them had we have the data
for 16 votes
so the
16 bluish boxes or belush circles on
this graph represent the inputs so the
votes so how did they vote on each of 16
issues
each of those has a no a an edge
connecting it to the output
each of those has a weight
and then our output node has a bias
so we've got 17 different values that we
have to
calculate we have to figure out what
they are so that we minimize the error
when we plug in those votes
we want to minimize the error
of the output value and the output value
is
either a zero or a one depending on
whether they are a Democrat or a
Republican
we still only have two political parties
in the U.S I don't know why that is but
actually some would say we only have one
but a different different subject
altogether
um
so if you can see it here there is
actually an equation
on the on this so the equation is how we
calculate that output node the output
the value of the output node is
the value that goes into the first node
times the first weight plus the value
that goes into the first a second node
times the second weight plus the value
that goes into the third node times the
third weight so V1 times W1 V2 times W2
of each all the way up to 16.
and then we add in that bias
and then we do one more thing we add in
what's called an activation function an
activation function just takes all of
those range of values that we can get
and turns it into a zero or a one so in
this case we're going to use What's
called the sigmoid function
um because any values less than minus
five basically go to zero any value is
greater than five go to one and there's
this nice smooth curve in the middle uh
that you know
makes it a zero to one value so we end
up with that output node having a value
of somewhere between zero and one
depending on what we calculated for it
and we want to minimize that error so we
want to find the values for those
weights and that bias that minimize that
error when we try all that data in there
that's what it means to train a machine
learning model
so let's look at some code
that does this let's uh let's jump into
Visual Studio here I'm a c-sharp
developer so I do most of my work in
Visual Studio
and this is the main program and this
code is all up on on GitHub so you'll be
able to pull it down it's linked at the
in the slide deck at the end
um
and you can see what we first do here is
the first thing was we split the data so
we take three quarters of it that's
going to be our training set and then
we're going to reserve 25 of that as our
test set we're going to test use that to
test to see how good our training was
for that particular instance
now you'll notice I did that here
outside the loop so I'm going to only
have one training set and one test set
and I'm going to keep trying this a
bunch of different times but I'm going
to use the same training data and test
data each time
the reason I did this here is because
it's faster and it doesn't
um it didn't seem to make a difference
for this problem
other problems it may be better to try
different training and test data inside
the loop you'll have to experiment with
your own particular problems
so we're going to Loop a bunch of times
and try this thing out and the what
we're going to do in those Loops is
we're going to train and test
so we're going to train the model and
then we're going to test it and see how
good it is and then we're going to look
for the highest accuracy
so it does did this training test cycle
when we tested it did it come out better
than others if so we're going to hold on
to that one
and that may be the one we end up using
and then of course we update a bunch of
Statistics so we can see how well we're
doing so let's drill into this train and
test model method that you see here and
you notice we send in
two things to that the training data set
and the test data set
so what do we do with that
here is our
train and test model method and of
course all we're doing is we're training
the model but we send into the train
method we send in three things the
training data set
that makes sense we also send in our
error function
and our activation function so that's
that sigmoid function that we saw the
graph of earlier
okay
so we're going to send those three
things into the training set
then we test it all we have to send in
is the test data because we already
we've already trained our model at that
point we already know what all those
values are so now we just try the test
data using the predict method and we'll
see that later
to see what predictions it makes and how
accurate those predictions are
in other words when it's predicts for
you know Congress person a
that they're a Democrat were they or
weren't they and if not
we have error and we have to take that
error into account
so let's drill into some of these other
things here's our error function
so the error function is just the sum of
the squares of all of the error
of all the errors for all of the data
the data points so we try every data
point
and you know every Congress person and
then whatever the value the calculated
value is remember we can calculate a
number between 0 and 1.
if it was supposed to be a one and we
got a 0.7 the error is 0.3 we square
that we add that all together and square
it and that's our total error
so we're going to need that we're also
going to need our activation function
and we've got three different activation
functions here the one we're using is
sigmoid that's at the bottom but I've
also got two others in there the no
activation function the one that just
allows it to be any value it wants
so whatever value it gets it Returns the
other most common one is is called relu
rectified linear units that basically is
it just chops it off at zero so if it's
zero or less the value is zero otherwise
it can go on to Infinity
um
in the positive direction now the
advantage of relu is that it's really
fast
very simple simple function so if you
have a ton of data
you may be better off using something
like that and and running all that data
lots of times
and maybe sacrificing the quality of the
of the activation function a little bit
in order to be able to run the data more
in this case I don't have a ton of data
so I don't mind using the slower but
kind of cooler looking function
may be more accurate
all right so those are our error
function and our activation function
and this is what our model looks like
so when we're training a model what
we're doing is we're calculating the
weights and bias
so at the bottom here you can see that
this has an array of weights and a bias
and the array of Weights is going to be
a array of size 16.
but we also hold the activation function
here in this model and we'll pass this
model around and be able to use it to
train
and test our data
so here is the first time we're actually
dealing with an amoeba all of that
previous stuff was kind of specific to
the solution it was specific to our
problem of trying to figure out who's
voting how and what their political
party is now we're going to start
training our model and so to train it we
have to have that amoeba and it's got to
do its work of of solving that that
problem of minimizing the error in our
model
so in this is where we configure the
simulation itself and you can see here I
have an amoeba size of 13 for this one
which I'm not really sure where I picked
13 because I really probably should have
picked 18 since we have 17 Dimensions to
this problem right 16 weights and one
bias
I've also got a Max epics in here of 70
and then there's some other values that
we can play with but I couldn't tell you
exactly what they do
then below that we have our objective
function that's the thing we're trying
to minimize
so it takes both the
it takes the voters the list of Voters
and it takes our activation function
and then what we do with that is we
configure the new organism that's our
amoeba
and we use its solve method
and the solve method what it's doing is
that spread is that flow chart we saw
earlier where it's just looping through
and moving the nodes around to try and
minimize that error
using the error function
all this code like I said is out there
for you to explore and play with and uh
figure out how to make it better
happy to take pull requests by the way
if you figure something out make it even
better love to love to add that to it
so here is now our predict method once
we've got the model fully trained once
we've minimized the error and we've said
all right this is the model we found the
set of
weights and bias
set of weights and the bias that
minimizes the error function now we can
use this predict method so we pass in a
voter's votes
those 16 votes and it comes back with a
value and it says this is either a
democrat or a republican so in this case
I just arbitrarily chose greater than
0.5 as a republican less than 0.5 is a
Democrat
um doesn't matter which is which as long
as you're consistent with it
and what it returns is
the result so Democrat or Republican and
a score and the score in this case is
just the actual value that we calculated
so if we got a 0.8 out of it
then we're going to say well that's uh
what a Republican
but we know that's not all the way right
a perfect a perfect score for a
republican would be one perfect score
for a Democrat would be zero but we only
got point eight so it gives us sort of a
probability it tells us how certain we
are
that that value is accurate
cool
so let's run this program sort of
and what we end up with is a display
like this you can see at the top
that we have some statistics and what we
found here is that our best our best
model was 95.7 percent accurate
considering we only had 400 data points
to work with that's really amazingly
good and what that tells me is even back
then it was pretty easy to predict what
what party someone was from based on
their votes
um and then taking that model that was
95.7 percent accurate
if we run it against all of the Congress
people in the list of running against
the entire voter list here are all of
the incorrect votes and the values that
they had
so not many failures but the failures
kind of seem kind of extreme like we
have the very first one is a a Democrat
and it was
99.98 if you want the value was
extremely Republican so maybe that
person is an outlier and and really
voted like a Republican or maybe our
model is just not really good at the way
that person voted at handling that
so
always interesting to explore these kind
of things in your problem and see is
there outliers in the data could you
clean the data up and make it look
better and make them make the model more
accurate
this is fun stuff to play with
wouldn't necessarily recommend doing
this yourself because there's really
good tools out there to train machine
learning models
but we can
and when we're in situations where there
isn't something that works well or if
there's a situation where
our problem is so huge that the typical
tools don't work well
we have these at our disposal
all right
there are
some more algorithms that are
bio-inspired that I enjoy talking about
some of which I I really don't want to
try the roast in roach infestation one I
don't know there's just some something
creepy about that one but there are lots
of things like particle swarm
optimizations and
bacteriophoraging and such I do an
entire talk in fact a couple of
different ones on genetic algorithms
because those are super fascinating and
as I mentioned at the beginning all of
these talks you could say are genetic
algorithms themselves the hard part
about genetic algorithms is actually
defining the problem
it's setting up the model in a way that
where you can describe the options in
the problem as if they were DNA
I do one where it's uh I
train a
model to play a game of Chutes and
Ladders or Snakes and Ladders I don't
know what what you call it here but it's
a kids game it's actually one where you
don't really get to make a decision if
you're playing the real game but we play
it like you get to choose do you want to
take a ladder or slide down a shoot or
not and then it has to figure out what's
the best strategy
and I describe each of those
moves each of those possible moves as
DNA and then allow
the organism itself to figure out what's
best and the best solution survive
really interesting stuff
all right
so what have we done today
we've minimize some costs and you saw
that we used that to train an AI model
by minimizing the error function
we did the Firefly and the amoeba
methods for uh minimizing cost we also
did a couple of best path algorithms so
finding the shortest path
between points
um I didn't talk much about it but uh
shortest path algorithms are kind of
interesting I mean it's mostly a solved
problem if you think about mapping but
it's used a lot in video games right you
have to you have your uh your pathing
algorithms to figure out what's the
fastest way to get from this point in
the world to the next point so I see
that kind of thing a lot in video games
uh
but the uh the best algorithms that we
use today are like you'll you'll see the
term a star
a Splat whatever a star algorithms
um those are exhaustive searches
so if you have a huge space that you
have to explore it can take a long time
to figure those out
um
a star is actually it's not entirely
exhaustive it's exhaustive up to the
point where you can prove that you going
any further doesn't help you anymore
you can't possibly get better
so super interesting stuff I I encourage
you to explore some of these things
because they're definitely interesting
all right so some resources
as I mentioned this slide deck is
available right now on the internet
amazing algorithms dot azure
azurewebsites.net
my blog is cognitive inheritance I don't
blog a lot but uh
when I do I'm very worried about it
um
so there's that and I do talk about some
of these things on there on occasion
I do have some other talks that are on
YouTube that are about this kind of
subject
there's one in particular that is
interesting in the same kind of way as
this talk and that's the building AI
Solutions with Google or tools so that's
or tools is operations research so
that's the minimum cost type functions
the finding the the lowest cost
a number of Articles from msdn magazine
where they talk about
algorithms like this I think those are
actually the four for these uh for these
four algorithms that we talked about
today
and then there are two sets of code that
I want to point out that are linked in
here uh the bottom one is the code to
this
that includes this demo so my AI demos
that include this algorithm this
optimization and then right above it is
the algorithms which is a
GitHub repo that is just a shared repo
all languages
any algorithm you can think of is
probably implemented there and if it's
not you should do that you should
implement it in whatever language you
prefer and contribute it and that's
there's lots of people that contribute
to those things I have contributed
several to
the algorithm so I encourage you to
check that out and experiment with it
and with that looks like we have about
10 more minutes so I'm happy to answer
any questions that I can
yes
so the question was basically how do you
choose an algorithm out of all these
amazing algorithms that we have and
really the best answer is and this it's
not going to be a very satisfying answer
the answer is you experiment with them
and you try it and you see what works
um whenever I'm implementing anything
the very first thing I do is I Implement
what's caused called a naive solution
think of the simplest thing that you can
possibly do and implement it that way
even though you know it's going to be
completely stupid right it's gonna
it may take forever or it may not find
an answer or whatever but first of all
what you do with that is you learn about
the problem you understand the problem
better
and then it gives you a Target if you're
building something else
and it doesn't even do as well as your
naive solution you know you don't need
to explore that option anymore
but yeah you're gonna basically have to
research and figure it out now some of
the tooling that we have today like if
you're looking at uh some of the
Microsoft tooling within visual studio
for example for training ml models
what it does is it tries a whole bunch
of different ways to optimize it and see
you know what works best so everything
that they have built into Visual Studio
there or in built into their uh
their dlls that they ship with Visual
Studio
they just try them all and see which one
works best and that's really the only
good way to do it other than to have
some intuition of which types of models
are going to work best for which types
of problems
sorry that I can't give you a better
answer than that but if there was one
we'd all be doing those things
if we had a genetic algorithm that would
try and yeah
what else it's hard to see so
yes
I've done I've used ml.net
um
no not for this uh so this was all done
in just pure code so it's it's straight
up C sharp um everything that you saw on
the screen and you'll see in GitHub is
just plain C sharp
so the um the part where you would have
normally used ml.net here
um was done by the
amoeba optimization routines that are in
there as well
yes
sometimes
okay so are so you're are you coming
from the python world is that what
you're
okay
so you're you're looking at what what
python-like algorithms or tools are
available in c-sharp to do machine
learning and really the best one is
probably ml.net
yeah
um that's that's Microsoft's
implementation and it does a lot of work
for you so if you have visual studio
um
uh there's a
how do you get it is it do you have to
use it as a not a plug-in but an
extension something like that and it
will actually if you give it a data set
it'll do a lot of that work for you to
figure out what's the best algorithm how
should it tokenize it a lot of that kind
of stuff is handled
anything else
oh cool I was happy to talk to you today
so thank you very much